>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Abby Nolan: I'm really
honored to introduce to you one
of the world's great
illustrators of children's books.
Jerry Pinkney has found
his calling early on
and was designated
the class artist back
when he was in elementary school.
In his career he has worked on
more than 100 children's books
and won countless awards.
He's adapted lots of fables and
folk tales, including The Tortoise
and the Hare, The Little Red
Hen, and The Lion and the Mouse
for which he won the
Caldecott medal.
But he has also illustrated
many other types of books,
and all of them feature beautifully
expressive artwork, playfulness,
warmth of feeling, and
intriguing details.
His latest is In Plain Sight,
which was written by Richard Jackson
and captures the sweet relationship
between a man and his granddaughter.
Mr. Pinkney will be signing
books from 2:30 to 3:30,
but in the meantime please help
me welcome him to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Jerry Pinkney: Well,
thank you, Abby.
And I want to thank certainly
everyone here for attending.
I mean, isn't this amazing?
It's amazing.
And this is probably my fourth time
here at the National Book Festival.
And I can't tell you, each time that
I enter in this space surrounded
by folks like yourselves, these
bright smiles, and this energy
that you don't get any other place.
So thank you for being here.
Today I'm going to be
presenting my new book,
a collaboration with
Richard Jackson.
He wrote the text.
And before I do that, though, I want
to talk about the how and the why
of how did I happen to actually work
with Dick Jackson on this project
and what was the pull to
me to illustrate this book?
Well, each book that I illustrate,
there has to be this opening
that allows me to actually inject
in the project something personal.
If we go all the way back to my
first book that was published
in 1964, which was The Adventures
of Spider, west African folk tales,
Anansi the spider, you see the
draw was being a person of color.
So all along what has to be there --
and I'm very blessed and fortunate
to have many, many projects offered
or that may come my way
-- how do I enter into it?
Now, if we talk about books that
I've reimagined from my childhood,
the connection certainly
is my childhood.
But in fact, if the
birthing of the text comes
from someone else, how do I enter?
So here we go.
We'll go into In Plain
Sight, again, by Dick Jackson.
The way it works in publishing is
that a publisher will acquire
a text, a story by an author.
Then the search is to find that
right artist that's appropriate
for that particular story.
Then the next step is
contacting that illustrator to see
if in fact he's interested.
Because the value in
illustrating someone else's text is
that you see value in it, that
you see it's an important project
for you to do.
So in this case I get
the text and it's a sort
of not hide-and-seek kind of a
game that a grandfather plays
with his granddaughter, Sophie.
So I'm looking for
that sort of opening.
What is pulling me to
illustrate this story?
Well, I have a nine-year-old --
at the time a seven-year-old
great granddaughter.
And what I thought was kind
of interesting is that --
and I couldn't figure this out,
that even at seven, if I would --
and they visit with us
often on the weekends.
So if I were to come home a
little later than they arrived
and she knew I was coming in the
door, in that room she'd hide.
And I couldn't figure
out, you know, at seven,
she's going to be eight soon and
she's still playing hide-and-seek.
And so what touched me in this
particular book, which is a seek
and find, is that young Sophie
actually hides from her grandfather.
So I'm going to introduce you to a
little bit about the other things
that lead into why a
project might be important.
So this is supposed to advance.
Okay, all right.
So this is my studio.
Now, a little bit more history.
The grandfather will hide objects.
So I was thinking about
this as well,
you know, how do I present this?
And I thought, "Why don't I
introduce you into another world
and another connection, my studio?"
And I love to collect.
So there you see my
studio, my drawing table.
By the way, you see that -- that's
a pheasant, which is a mount
that I've been actually
doing drawings of.
But I'm fascinated with objects.
So you can see that's another pool.
Sophie's grandfather
actually hides objects.
And I love objects.
As a matter of fact, I'm
a little over the top.
This is just a -- it's a
table, and it's a table --
the purpose of this table is
really to hold some of the things
that I'm most interested in.
I love to walk in the woods.
I love feathers, shells,
anything that gives me a sense
of I think it's just the
tactile feel of things.
And if I'm interested in nature,
what better way to introduce nature
into my life, into my studio but
through the collection itself?
So now, here's what
I didn't discover.
Remember I said this story
is sort of a seek and find?
And so went I present --
and I just presented this
to school children the
other day, and it came to me
if we look very closely at
the image, there is a --
got to help me -- there's a
dinosaur -- I'll give you a clue --
that's orange, and then
there's a small rabbit.
Now this was not done on purpose.
Has nothing to do with this
book other than the fact
that you can see that's a kind of a
bridge into this story that makes --
because I will oftentimes --
sometimes I use these little,
small animals as research,
as models.
And what I love to
do is just plop them
down anywhere, somewhere
in the studio.
So here we go.
The models.
And I knew in this case
the models would have
to in some way know each other
and relate in order to talk
about this very important
relationship.
So we have here Sophie, and
that's her real grandfather.
Okay. So now, I've set this up
so that you can help me as well.
That's the room.
Now, Sophie's grandfather
is wheelchair-bound
and his universe really is
the universe of his room.
So we'll talk about maybe at the end
how important it is for me to talk
about even though his
world is a small world,
he's confined to a wheelchair
so he doesn't leave that room,
he still has powerful interests.
And also, I want you to watch
out for can you tell something
about Sophie's grandfather
through looking at the pictures?
So that's his room.
I'll give you a little clue.
You know that there's a banjo case?
Can you we assume that
he's a musician?
Maybe. All right, that's the
title page that you guys know
that introduces you,
really, to the relationship
between this powerful
grandfather and the powerful love
that a grandfather has
for his granddaughter.
Okay. Now ready?
Sophie lives with mama, and daddy,
and grandpa, who lives
by the window.
He can see Sophie come and go,
call and wave goodbye,
hello as he looks out.
Here's where I need your guys' help.
And after school each
day, Sophie looks in.
"Here I am, grandpa," she says.
"How was the morning?"
Surprisingly he says, "I had me a
paperclip, you know, nice and shiny.
Now it's vanished.
Help me find it, will you,
with your bright eyes?"
"Where?" says Sophie?
"That's just it, honey,
you have to look."
Ah. If you lean close, you
might hear Sophie say, "Oh,"
and eventually you find you find
you might hear her say, "There."
"Good," says grandpa.
"Thanks honey."
"Here I am," says Sophie on Tuesday.
"Ah, Sophie," he says,
"how was school?"
"Good, it was a blue day."
"Well, I can see that."
"And how about you, grandpa?"
"Today was regretful.
Oh, yes. Had me a rubber
band -- stretchy, boing.
Now boing, that band has gone.
Help me find it, huh?"
And eventually in plain sight,
Sophie finds the rubber band.
"Here I am, grandpa,"
says Sophie on Wednesday.
"Was today better?"
"Not so much," grandpa says.
"Had me a drinking straw
-- bendy, just right.
You remember.
Now it's skedaddled."
Now, what I want you to do, and I
know it's very difficult for you
to do it here, but
search the image and see
if you find the drinking straw.
But I'll give you a clue.
It's on the window frame.
So the idea of the
book is, of course,
you'll go back and forth with that.
"I'll look," says Sophie.
I wonder, and eventually
in plain sight.
"Good girl," grandpa says.
"Thanks." Now, you notice
something else is happening here is,
of course, is the days of the week.
On Thursday Sophie says,
"Here I am, grandpa.
Anything missing?"
The other thing you'll
notice, he had this feeling
that maybe Sophie is
in on this game.
You think so?
On Thursday Sophie says,
"Here I am, grandpa.
Anything missing?"
"Well, wouldn't you know
grandma's favorite painting brush
for water colors, child.
I'm missing that.
Can you help me?
Lovely." "I can try," says Sophie.
And eventually, in plain sight.
So I don't know how well
you guys are doing on this,
I imagine that kids with their sharp
eyes may be a little keener, right?
"Here I am, grandpa."
What day is it now?
>> Friday.
>> "Here I am, grandpa,
Friday at last."
"You bet, honey," he says,
turning his smile to her.
But wait, just look.
"Oh, grandpa, you silly."
"Keep the dollar, Sophie.
Tomorrow," he says, "you can
buy yourself something with it."
So did you guys ever try to
put a dollar in your sort
of eye socket between your eyebrow?
I tried it.
You've tried it?
Yeah, were you successful?
Yeah, I had a hard time with that.
Anyway. "So here I am,
grandpa," Sophie says.
"Early today."
"No shopping?
Well, best to save that
dollar, I guess, for college.
Now, let's see.
Okay. Had me a what?
A lemon drop -- delicious
to think of --
but then it just trotted
off unlicked."
"Don't tell me, grandpa."
And eventually, in plain sight.
"Good girl," says grandpa.
"No, no, you have it, Sophie."
Sunday morning, as usual, at his
door Sophie starts to say, "Grandpa,
here I" -- but mama hushes her.
He's sleeping, which
gives Sophie an idea.
She whispers it to mama.
Daddy laughs when he hears.
"All right," he says,
"if you tiptoe."
Here's Sophie at her
quietest, her tiptoeingest.
The curtains at grandpa's
window, well, keep your eye on it.
And eventually where's Sophie?
Grandpa wakes, oh, yawns.
Ah. Behind the curtain a commotion
-- wiggly, jiggly, and giggly.
Sophie's grandpa says, "That's you.
Well, I'll be."
"Here I am, grandpa," Sophie says.
"Here I am like always."
Now, here's the thing.
The book is really very much
like, again, that what I look for.
Well, I have a great-granddaughter
and she's
with us mostly on the weekends.
We have her two cats.
And by the way, you'll see how the
role of the cat in all of this.
But Sophie -- my granddaughter
Zion who, again,
loves to play hide-and-seek.
And as a matter of fact, she brings
me back to a kind of youthfulness
that I've almost lost until
my great-granddaughter.
One of the things I wanted to
do with [inaudible] was to talk
about that relationship,
but I also wanted
to talk a lot about the grandfather.
And I wanted to talk about
his sort of back stories.
So when deciding where to hide
the objects, I chose places
where it would sort of demonstrate
and speak to this world that --
and a well-lived life
of the grandfather.
So the paperclip is in the
band of a soldier's cap.
So it suggests -- it
just suggests that he was
in the Army at one point.
And then of course, the rubber
band was wrapped around a football.
And the role of the artist
is to actually build a world,
to build sort of a visual
world for the readers.
And you'll notice next
to the football might be a
trophy, a football trophy.
So I'm letting you in on something
or I'm actually letting
you read the pictures.
So not only is it a search
and find, but it also deals
with the life of this grandfather.
So it goes on, of course.
Then you have the -- trying to think
of the order of the paintbrush,
which was that we get a sense that
the grandmother was a painter.
And that's, of course,
of value to him.
So it goes on.
Of course, the lemon drop.
Who could resist a
lemon drop, right?
Exactly. So that's
in a box of marbles.
Now, how did I decide about marbles?
Because when I was a kid
I loved playing marbles.
And so that you can see not only
in my illustrations working towards
speaking to the story itself,
the text itself, but
we're also giving --
I'm giving you a part of my life.
Now, if you guys venture
into buying the book,
I want you to look under the cover.
You guys, underneath the
cover -- you can't see it now.
So that means you really
have to buy the book.
But the case cover, it's not
only the objects that you find
in the book that the grandpa hides,
but also on the case cover are the
tools that I used to make the book.
So you'll find in this illustration
pencils that I used, pastels,
of course, water colors,
and pencils.
Now, pencils is the
really the instrument
or the drawing tool of choice.
And a little story about that
because I had an interview earlier.
And we were talking about
the love of drawing.
And I said, "You know what's
so cool about all this?"
I was just thinking about this.
I said, "If you read about me,
and I write a lot of pieces,
essays on my process, and the medium
is pencil and water color on paper."
Okay. So I write a lot about the
fact that, again, that tool --
instrument of choice -- to help
me make marks is the pencil.
Now, here's the thing
that I just thought about.
When I was a kid growing up, I
didn't have access to art materials.
My parents weren't museum
or gallery visitors at all.
They didn't have a cool
understanding of what an artist was.
What's interesting is although they
supported their young son's need
to draw, so I always
had materials at hand.
Here's the cool part.
I grew up on a very small street
in the Germantown section
of Philadelphia.
All of the neighbors
were African-Americans
who migrated south.
Outside of that world were
Jewish and Italian communities.
So in the '40s we were
somewhat isolated.
In order to keep the young boys
somewhat busy in a positive way,
we were encouraged to draw.
And my parents didn't have a sense
about what art might lead to,
but the boys were actually
encouraged to draw
as a positive way to use that time.
I'm going to go back to the fact
that the pencil as instrument
of choice on that block
of row homes,
and the end of that block
there was a factory.
The factory was a pencil factory.
And my grandfather
worked in the factory.
And he would bring
home lots of pencils.
So here's the thing about being an
artist for you parents out there
and grandparents that might have
children that are interested
in drawing -- that
key piece that started
when I was a very young child,
the fashion and the love
for making a mark and then
making a mark with the pencil.
And that has stayed with me over
the course of some almost --
my first book was published in 1964.
It was done in pencil
with color washes.
And today when I get up in the
morning and most days when I get
up in the morning and
I walk to the studio,
I sit down at my drawing board,
and most often I pick up a pencil.
Thank you, Grandfather Charles.
Thank you, guys.
Well appreciated.
[ Applause ]
All right.
I think that's it.
Our time's up, right?
I have two minutes.
Do I have two minutes if there's
a question in the audience?
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jerry Pinkney: Do
I ever get frustrated
when my drawing doesn't turn
the out way I want it to be?
As a young artist you did
because you're always searching
for an idea actually to build on.
I will tell you this, though, the
frustration as an adult artist tends
to lead to a better result.
Why? Because frustration means
that what you see that comes
to mind first is not working.
Most oftentimes in order
to do a more original idea,
you have to dig a little deeper.
And the gateway to sometimes
digging deeper is frustration,
that something isn't work and
then how do I make it work?
That's a very good question.
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jerry Pinkney: Oh thank
you, thank you very much.
How are we doing time-wise?
Oh, yes, we have time
for another question.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Jerry Pinkney: You might
have to help me, I can't --
when did I start drawing?
How old are you?
Six? Yeah, I started when I
was probably -- you know what?
To tell you the truth, I
think I started as soon
as my parents gave me something
to mark with and mark on.
And by the way, mark on --
at one point I just have
to tell you a little bit
about my father's encouragement.
I was on a bunk bed.
I had the top bunk.
And guess what?
I would sometimes draw on the wall.
But however -- this is it --
my father never scolded me.
You know what he did?
Every once in a while he would paint
over the drawing and
I would start again.
Thank you, thank you very much.
Thank you for your
smiles and your support.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.